now as we've been talking about labor
leadership in Iran there are other
issues between to talk about on the
program including the high-speed rail
link and now the former deputy chaired
the government's review into HST has
today released him a dissenting report
where he claims taxpayers are set to
lose 40 billion pounds on the project
after Parliament was misled about its
costs let's just remind ourselves of
what hs2 actually is it's a high-speed
rail line connecting London to cities in
the north of England the line will form
a Wye shape so it starts in London ghost
Birmingham and splits towards Manchester
in one direction and leads in the other
but the cost of the project has been
repeatedly revised upwards and it's also
have been beset by delays
well Boris Johnson set up a review to
look into the project when he became
prime minister but the Deputy Chair of
the review panel will Barclays left his
role in November saying he'd had no
opportunity to influence its conclusions
and he's now released his own Road
reports and he joins us now thank you
very much for being with us so you were
so disillusioned with the official
report if you like commissioned by the
government that you've produced your own
what's in it my report suggests that the
the project is completely out of control
financially it doesn't that you do
what's in the tin because it doesn't
benefit the north and the Midlands and
the way that upgrading existing lines
could and also they fiddled the figures
to improve the benefit cost ratio by
allowing for 18 trains an hour to go and
not line when nobody in the world runs
more than 14 so the revenues all shot to
pieces really I mean fiddle the figures
there's quite a strong accusation that
you're making it you affect I mean who
fiddled the figures vastly and secondly
are you saying that Poland's been misled
I believe that Parliament's been misled
because the the costs were clearly known
to the Department of Transport and I
believe ministers three or four years
ago there's a lot of evidence that and
that the cost of that stage they were
saying well it probably they were over a
hundred billion now I think the figure
which I believe is about right is 107
billion
it's an enormous figure and Parliament
should have had an opportunity to debate
this these estimates they want they I
mean people just
- go on effectively you know they're
best gas don't they I mean the figures
are always gonna be right well
everything's an estimate but on the
other hand people are complaining I
think quite right here that Crossrail
has gone up in maybe 25% cost increase
now that's at the end of construction
this project is probably two or three
times over budget even before the
construction has started now that's a
completely different level of cost
overrun and it does need does need
looking at again you of course with
Deputy Chair Theo Kaffee report which
was the one that set up by the
government to look into HS - what should
happen with it nine out of the ten panel
members have stuck by even those who
were quite skeptical about HS - so why
are they are they wrong and you're the
one who's right well I don't know
there's after you'll have to ask them
but I mean I believe I'm right because
having talks to many people in the
region's many people involved in this I
am convinced that the real problem is
that the railways in the regions in
particular the north and the midlands
are really bad and it's them that need
investment from local commuters and
people wanted to get about their
business they're getting to London is
secondary for most people that accepts
four members of parliament and
politicians like me maybe and managing
directors of companies so attracting
business to these areas will be done by
improving the commuter services
dramatically to make him look like more
like the London one services which are
very good at the same time they people
who working in the region's many of them
are very supportive of HS - can have a
look for example at some quotes starting
off with Andy Street who's the mayor of
the West Midlands he said we need a
commitment to something that I'm certain
will be seen for generations to come was
a critical investment to the future of
the country and will drive the economic
revival of the Midlands and the north
can also have a look at Judith Blake the
leader of Leeds City Council she says by
delivering hs2 and northern powerhouse
rail will transform towns and cities
across the north helping to attract
investment and provide good quality jobs
for decades to come
so why are these people who are in Leeds
who are in Birmingham saying that if you
could think well I've asked them I've
spoken to Andy at some length the yes
better rail services will probably bring
investments but whether it's better rail
services which are better commuter
services which in a Birmingham area are
pretty awful friendly or getting to
London 10 minutes quicker is a debate
that had nobody's answered and I suggest
that the companies who they say will be
attracted into Birmingham and Manchester
and Leeds if they had a decent commuter
services to get a bigger workforce able
to come in and compete for jobs in the
area it's actually more important than
getting to London a bit more quickly now
we spoke to dominant Robert early on a
program the foreign secretary he
reiterated the government's commitment
to HS to you but there has been some
speculation about how warm or not warm
Boris Johnson ears about the project and
that potentially the report was
effectively we're buying him more time
if we're to make a decision I mean you
have a pretty good idea don't you of
where the government's mine is on it
what do you think they'll end up doing
with HS today well I don't know I mean I
haven't talked about ISM you know I
submitted my report and no doubt he'll
think about it but for me HS - if it if
it were almost cancelled except for a
bit in the northern powerhouse area and
replaced by about half the investment on
local services local rail network in the
north and the Midlands it would be much
better for everybody who lives up there
and you know saving 50 billion at this
stage I think is quite something that
he'll want to look at okay I thank you
very much for coming on the program
today and for giving us the details if
that people that you are publishing
thank you very much thank you thank you
now a spokesperson for HST Limited has
centres the following statement in
response to that interview HST Limited
has provided full cooperation to mr. oak
V and his review team and if the
government decides to proceed we have a
highly skilled team in place ready to
build Britain's new railway investment
is a state-of-the-art
a house we line is critical for the UK's
low carbon transport future and will
provide much needed
capacity up and down the country and it
is also integral to rail projects in the
north and Midlands which will help
rebalance the UK economy so that was the
HS 2 there and we've also heard the
following statement from the Department
of Transport they've said the government
commissioned that oqv reviewed to
provide advice on a how and whether to
proceed with HST with an independent
panel representing a range of viewpoints
Lord Barclays support represents his
personal view